Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Resident Evil 7.
Now!
We, uh, lost Zoey somehow, so I guess I gotta get back in this perfectly pristine boat that I'm sure is mine here we go
Well, I couldn't have gotten far
You know how she was unconscious Joe? I mean come on I know
You've been hit in the head a few times. Oh hey well there they are *laughs*
God what did I expect?
*Laughs some more* What did I expect?
I mean honestly and truly what did I- well that's not normal. Huh weird huh? Oh?
You're gonna get it alright
Oh-ho, Joe mad
Joe MyID
alright well
Joe maybe you should ask what happened to, uh, Jack and his the rest of his family. What about your your your nephew Lucas, huh?
Yeah oddly enough considering that this is after Evelyn is dead, or if Evelyn is dead
I'm pretty sure Evelyn's dead, but this is after all of that so honestly who knows
Why this is still like spreading an infection I mean I?
Don't know if he's got to be that looks like hangman's noose
But like why does why well like I know it's it's probably perfect environment for a fungus to thrive
But I thought it was all psychically controlled by Evelyn or maybe Evelyn was the only one keeping it in check
and without Evelyn like
Everything has gone to shit. You know what I mean like everything is just burnt up destroyed and
You know all control is lost. It's like if just to get a nerdy reference to it if if like in
StarCraft how the zerg will run rampant or in World of Warcraft how
without the Lich King you know all the undead will just spread out and cause chaos on a rampage without control and
maybe that's just what's going on here I
Mean in the end. It's just a fungus right so would just do whatever it wants to do
Which is be a fungus and infect things and cause rampage what have you but you know?
You'd think that fire bombing the entire area would have been the best Avenue for all this wait is this wait?
Oh wait. This is this is the Baker family residence
Oh!
*Quietly chuckles*
Love you game a little oh, that's a real one. Okay, all right. That's a real one all right. Hey Bosque
Don't be so dramatic
All right, what do we got? Ooh more? Okay? That's some Mo-re
All right, can I have that can I go up here too? No? Great! All right? Well. I'm cut off
I gotta go down here and
Spear you in the gullet. IN THE GULLET. Okay? What's in here? GRUB I hope
Grab no grub oh damn it
Refrigerators are the number one source of grub!                                                    (Marki-Fact 134)
All right fine, then hope I can make another bomb
with my... Medicine. *chuckles*
Ooh is IT GRUB? oh
Oh god you're so cute! Oh, you're so cute! OH GOD!
You're so cute in my microwave!
Oh god it's so cute. I almost don't want to pick you up and eat you
Oh God Look at him!
He's. He's just like!
"Hi! Welcome to my home oh, please make yourself at home I can cook you up something real nice!" oh my god he's so cute!
God I'm gonna call you Steve
Steve I can't bring myself to take you Steve. "All right! See ya! Have a good one!" (Call me later B.B)
"I'll forgive you for eating my brother. That's all right everybody gotta eat something!"
Steve
Steve I'm sorry I even tried Steve. I hope you have a lovely day
I'll never eat another crawdad in my life even though. I got another one my inventory, and I'm probably gonna turn into goop juice
That's okay. You have a nice day
All right Steve. See ya
Oh Steve! Uh Oh.
You ain't Steve oh?
You want a bomb are you?
All right, well Steve is steve is doing this thing Steve is doing Steve's thing hey
I could probably just slip by you couldn't yeah, I probably could
I'm gonna go for it. Oh
Oh, oh, oh, Skewy (Scary). All right which way you goin' asshole?
Oh, okay, you're just patrolling back and forth okay. I think I can s- ah nah.
Maybe uh it's hard to say whoa hello. Where'd you come from I think I could
Yeah, if I just move it's close
I'm going I'm going ah ScARy all right
Okay Wow skill whiskey whiskey whiskey we Oh Bob fluid why why does that keep opening up V o V does that okay?
All right, okay well can they make another bomb?
There we go I don't any goop juice got grub for that
This scrap metal over there, but would it be worth yeah
All right, it's gonna go wrong
Okay I
Got to garden that one so you have to
You have to get through that one somehow. Oh it left. Oh, it's both of them. Oh they just moved
Oh, that's that's clever of them. I don't know why they're bothering to garloo
Hey baldie, where you go? Oh a path way over there you say oh?
Wait no. That's just oh, they're just guarding that depository. Oh, hey watch yourself. I'll bomb you I will bomb you Oh
What do you do? What's your objective here buddy? What's your objective? What's your objective your friend all right? Well you large?
crocodilians are
not welcome here question mark
All right, so I got a spear one of these guys in the butthole I
Choose you oh
All right well actually I don't think I'll be able to get by this one either
Dude up
Clowns ah more bomb-making fluid yes, all right. I've got bombs all right. That's right you went away. Oh
Be back, who'd have thought
okay, wait ah
Does this just connect both of them? Oh so I could have snuck by?
uh, I could have snuck by Ah without wasting any spear
Okay, all right. Well waste not want not which is what I should have said now the
Word that I want isn't what I'm saying so I have no idea what I'd want to say anyway
I'm gonna continue on and punch so oh my god. I'm gonna punch something hello
punchable z--
Hmm okay, how you gators doing out there? I can't get close to that window all right Effigy
Bomb!!
Yes! I love the bomb
I Love stick bomb love stick bomb all right anyway now that it got stick bomb
ooh
Oh Steve it's your friend, aww god I can't bring
Myself and I know that in my bag of grub is Steve somewhere
Ooh
I can't do it. Oh god. Why can't I take all this totally fresh mackerel here? Oh no
No, no. Oh damn it. Okay. All right, then well
Whoa whoa something tells me going down this ladder
Well might be an if fun adventure all right seems to be a lot of ways to get back up
I'm thinking that maybe it's gonna drop me down. It seems like a distinct possibility. Hey. How do you get down there?
I wanna get down there,
a you
Ah, I think maybe you get down there by dropping down and swimming which is not something. I'm eager to do
Although there might be Effigy's, I'll stick whoa hey hey. Hey well. What are you doing here?
Oh no oh, no wait wait wait wait and there you go Bob's your uncle whoa I
Thought I saw something over there. Hey stop it. Just roll off. Yeah
Okay
Oh
ohhh ohhh
Okay all right oh
Love it. Oh hello what the no?
Uh oh, uh oh, uh oh ,uh oh
I am out of oh I don't have any steaks left
Noooo!!!
Oh, oh my bottocks!! My buttocks has been bitten!!
ow, ow, ow
Geez ouch ouch, okay, all right, then well that didn't work out, too
Well some tells me I might want to commit some sticks to the spear variety
Oh man, but I don't want to waste all my sticks for potential bombs
That's rude ludicrous all right fine then
Ow ow, HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
Ookay, alright, well
ow, ow ouchy! Ooo
Something tells me that I should be capable of wrestling a gator with my bare hands
But that ain't happenin. Oh well anyway, we commit another one of these to that again carry on
man death sure is final here
All right very carefully very carefully at full breakneck speed very carefully all right come on
No, no
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh the finisher baby
Ooh
I got sticking come in another one to the to the spare alright, come on now. Oh
Oh, boom baby oh yes
Boom! it was like a walking shadow over there
Boom!
Miss me I mean you hit me, but it didn't it didn't hurt, so hey
Hello well you got a lot of bruises
There goes your arm. I guess that's good enough as a head
Alright, bonk the throne spear and bomb fluid bomb fluid. Oh, I'm out of branches god. I shouldn't have made
Oh, I shouldn't have made that last one into a spear. I knew I shouldn't I should've listened to Steve
Got it
Gotta get gotta get fisty a little exercise every now and then alright so I can make my way into that
Which I guarantee there's gonna be some Gators, but if I can make my way over there
There's a lot of Spears, so I'm gonna go for it
Okay woo nope
If I waste too many Spears getting to this then there was no point
But hey it looks like I got a net surplus of Spears
right
Honk-bonk bomb fluid yes
All right, I gotta eat a grub, but I hope it's not Steve
Oh good, oh good
Good for the tum-tum all right, where are we going?
Okay all right then uh, oh well that ain't good
Okay, what do you garden? What are you garden over there anything?
I'm gonna scout from above before I actually commit to going down there, but what do you garden?
It looks like nothing, but I don't trust that
Yeah, hello medal what we got over here oh
All right well I meant to use a bomb for you, but I guess oh
Hey, wait hang on wait you gonna break through that you'll be soon. Hey delivery
hey hey buddy, he he didn't notice the door shattering behind him
Shit well hang on wait, stealth kill I just needed to warm up warm up hit from from hitty
Wait this must all be mine because that is very clearly the football
Place that I went to I guess everybody must have went there, but man. Why is everybody living in a swamp?
Why is everybody living in a swamp?
All right hang on. I gotta leave a present. It's Christmas
You didn't hear nothing. What are you talking about?
My app who's there I?
Hear some slapping oh you're not dead. How are you not dead? I stomped you all right well
It's so much all right anything else in here then I need no sticks a garlic yes fresh
Okay, carrying on
Geez so funny
Boink boink boink boink
All right, what do we got?
What was that thing garden down there was there? There's something down there, but I just don't know if I should go for it
Cuz seems all blocked up here. I'll look around if it's
It's necessary. I'll go for it, but I don't know
Bomb fluid they sure are giving me a lot of that
Okay, yeah, I'm thinking that maybe it was over the other way
Hey, what's going on here?
Right in the dick, right in the dick, right in the dick, ow
a grub apparently
Apparently a grub wasn't enough to survive hang on rewards earned are clear
after clearing the game won't what lower the difficulty level no oh
No
No way come on. What are you saying? I know how to do this. Yeah, just
What are you thinking? What are you thinking about? What are you doing?
I got this you think I don't got this hang on wait
I just got to leave leave a little a little bit of a present here
Blink dudu to just gotta hang on
Just got distract this guy long enough boom. Oh well Merry Christmas
Okay, well are you all dead?
Good a stick a nice stick. I love me a good stick all right. I'm gonna make some medicine
I guess I guess I'll make some but at first time I ate this last grub better not be a crawdad. Oh good good
good
well
Hello? ah
Whose behind me oh
Whoa
Whoa whoa that guy grub in a box that guy did not
That guy did not have a lot of hutspa, okay, so how do you get under there?
There's got to be a way right it must be where that Gator was guarding
And I want to go back because I'm pretty sure there's probably another effigy over there, and that's probably a croc, ooh
There's oh I see an effigy right there. All right. You know what how my Spears. I got seven Oh
Hell's to the yeah all right. Let's do this
All right, let's do this come on
One
who want some, who wants some, who wants some Yeah? Yeah, yeah, yeah?
Okay, all right. He's not going for me. Just yet. Oh hell yeah champion
What's that light over there anything important?
Not to the ocean
Okay, miss, which is my first Miss. I'm allowed one miss, but that's it
Was this just a light yeah, nothing important, okay? I don't think I have to hit that guy, but just in case
Wanna be thorough
Okay, what do we got over here?
So I don't think this is the way to get in there. Maybe it is maybe it is ooh
It is it is yes all right, so what's under here. That's good. Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh
shit everything oh, oh shit oh
Yeah Steve
Steve I'd never I would never you out you have that delicious eye Steve Steve you have a wonderful time with that
Eye, all right Steve
And say thank you. See you around how do I?
What's that over there? How do I get that oh?
I want whatever that is. I don't even know what it is. I can't even tell
All right, I gotta go back for that. I know I know I don't have to go back for that
I could just press on forward, but I want to just be completionist about it for some stupid reason
Anything over here no okay? I'll be right back. Oh. No that was a one-way path oh
Titty sprinkles okay, whatever I got the champion my punching ability is a little bit better than it was before so that's good
I probably missed out on another small effigy, but as long as I got the champion. I think that's okay all right
Let's do this. What is this?
What is it for was what building was this what this used to be?
Ba-am
all right whoa
Jeez that door was awfully squishy
Hello save point ah there we go there. We go all right
Okay
Hello, Rock. Don't be a crawdad yes the centipede a delicious centipede alright anybody over
Anybody hello, this is rather ominous am I going back up towards the house
Crawdad grub. Yes
you guys hear that?
Something is squishing its way through the forest and I don't like it. What is that?
A church what how long's this been here? What the hell?
Where the hell am I?
Why am I here?
Geez why am I making my way through all this. What's the point?
I don't know good. Good final stand area though looks very uh
Very ominous and horrifying centipede
Grub, it's almost like they're dosing me up for something huh well gonna make another bomb and that's that
Yeah, you'd think I'd find more sticks in the forest here, but apparently not okay, all right
Whoa, whoa, whoa,
Whoa, whoa, whoa, ok alright Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, alright, whoa, whoa, whoa
What the hell whoa whoa what the hell whoa?
Whoa whoa, whoa, whoa? I don't know what happened there. I think I got cornered whoo Wookiee. I don't like you
I'm gonna put a bomb right here
Bomb
Let's not be you guys
Right under your dick
Bonk hey hey, hey look under your feet oh no your balls. Oh, yeah
Ow, how am I gonna punch you answer is I'm probably not
All right in your face can I punch you I'm gonna punch you right in your big bloated belly
Oh bonk, bonk, bonk, boom woo, man that no one was like a one punch fist
Alright, well you used up all my Bam's
You sack of shit alright fine, then I'll make do without you creepy son of a bitch habuski, habuski, habuski
Habuski all right Sebastian Castellanos in here right now anybody hello boxer effigy
Okay, good my punching power is back up to snuff
punch punch punch punch
The punch of Prayer oh hello, what are you doing? Here Zoe? How did you get here Zoe? Ah?
Yes Zoe
Yes, it is yes indeed it is
Okay, yeah, what would?
You think that somehow like this is the essence of Joe bacon of Jake Jack Baker
Come on ma overpower yeah, there you go, oh
Geez oh geez it is Jack. Oh, it is Jack
Jack I should recognized those hittin fists. They both like to punch real good
Jack Jack What the fuck, Oh
Jack come on now Jack. This is ridiculous
your own brodda, oh boy jack
You think I'd be a little more concerned as to what the hell is this what the hell's going on?
Well that's one way what he couldn't punch me to death oh geez
One one-inch punch break out of it
What the hell
God dammit don't know how I got out
Thought Jack was completely dead
But I guess maybe when maybe when Evelyn oh
Look more coffins
Is that his common way of just getting rid of people that he doesn't like - throwing them into coffins?
Is that what it is yeah?
Maybe when Evelyn died like because his his personality was like distilled into Evelyn like psychically or whatever
But who knows what happened after she died
So all
All these soldiers all these soldiers with these with these guns and what not and shooty shooty bang Bang's
They can't they can't bring him down, but me with my fists
One-on-one whoo, baby, we got a stew going alright. That's all the time. I got for this episode
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know anything down the comments below and as always I'll see you in the next video